I'm going to show you an effect
of quantum physics, which
is currently being investigated
to actually include
in computers.
Now, what Ilya is
bringing on is a tray
containing something
called a high-temperature
superconductor.
That's that grey
blob in the middle.
But the high-temperature
superconductor
only behaves as a superconductor
at very low temperatures.
That's why he's poured in
liquid nitrogen into this.
Because what happens
is as follows.
As you lower the temperature
of the superconductor,
the electrons in the
material get a chance
to actually act as a crowd.
Usually they're kind of
to being buffeted around
by the other atoms
in the material.
But when you lower things
down in temperature,
they can act as a crowd.
In fact, what they do, and
hence the word superconductor,
is that this crowd
is so strong that it
can kind of march
through the material
without any resistance.
In fact, that's the key.
There's no resistance.
It's a superconductor.
And we're going to see
what the effect of that is.
Because if there are electrons
marching around as a group,
that's actually like a current.
And the current gives
rise to magnetic field.
So I'm going to put
on these goggles.
I'm actually going
to check out what
magnetic field and whether
there's a magnetic field coming
out of this material
and therefore,
if it's acting as
a superconductor.
What I'm taking here
is a tiny magnet
that I'm actually going to place
on top of the superconductor.
Oh, although, I tried
to place it on top,
and it's actually floating.
Now, this is bizarre.
But that's what you get
in the quantum world.